este es un día que raoni mentiré
esperaba con impaciencia tras haber
pasado varios meses en la ciudad
recuperándose del coronavirus que
contrajo en agosto el gran jefe kayapó
de 92 años finalmente regresó a su
pueblo tenía muchas ganas de volver a mi
casa desde hacía mucho tiempo y ahora
estoy mejor
un viaje de casi una hora por encima de
la que defiende desde hace más de 50
años la selva amazónica incansablemente
devorada por la deforestación los
monocultivos de soya y las minas de oro
clandestinas como está visible desde la
ventanilla hay una nueva amenaza a
puertas del territorio kayapó a un
virgen de toda invasión y philip barre
llega a descubrirlo por primera vez
sin emoción
es una emoción increíble ver estas
partes del mundo todavía preservadas que
deben darnos un motivo para seguir
luchando
para tratar de que las cosas cambian en
nuestra cotidianidad porque en efecto
este tipo de devastación tiene que ver
con nuestro consumo con occidentales
me invitó hoy a este responsable de una
ong a su pueblo blanco go es porque su
asociación viene a ofrecerle un apoyo
jurídico respaldado por su pueblo raoni
acaba de presentar una denuncia a este
22 de enero contra el presidente
brasileño jair bolsonaro ante la corte
penal internacional de la haya por
crímenes contra la humanidad
exterminación y esclavización de pueblos
autóctonos
raoni está en duelo por su esposa
fallecida a causa del cobi 19 en junio
según la tradición kayapó él no debería
salir de su casa pero de todas maneras
invitó a 14 jefes kayapó y también de
otras sedes
todos los pueblos de jim una labor de
largo aliento
negaron el sobrino de ramón y los
convenció uno por uno
los que apoyan allá bolsonaro están en
contra de nosotros
va a cubrir en que quieren destruir
nuestro río y nuestro pueblo va
y si bolsonaro fuera juzgado aquí por la
justicia kayapó en la justicia kayapó
las personas malas que tienen una mala
influencia que no respetan a los demás
son expulsadas son desterrados de aquí
[Música]
la denuncia es el resultado de más de
dos años de trabajo en familia durante
los cuales raoni le enseñó todo su saber
a sus nietos
machado y berduc
debemos seguir su ejemplo pero sobre
todo debemos aprender de él
de cómo lleva a cabo sus luchas siempre
nos dice deben adquirir los
conocimientos de los blancos y conocer
la manera en la que trabajan los blancos
utilizar sus armas para defender su
territorio
el objetivo de la asociación francesa es
que gracias a su ejemplo otros jefes de
diferentes etnias brasileñas se
conviertan en co denunciantes es
necesario que a través de esta denuncia
se reconozca el derecho de los pueblos
indígenas a ser respetados en su
territorio en su cultura y según las
demarcaciones de sus territorios que hoy
en día son muy trabajadas
la demarcación de las tierras indígenas
es una de las principales violaciones
señaladas en la denuncia el que se ha
enfrentado a varios presidentes hoy en
día no ve otro recurso posible más que
la justicia internacional trate de
acudir a la justicia brasileña pero
nadie me puso atención entonces fui a
francia y hablé con el abogado de la
asociación para que me escuchará y para
que denunciáramos juntos a bolsonaro
para que definitivamente se ha apartado
del poder para que por fin estemos
tranquilos es a causa de él que un jefe
del pueblo guajará fue asesinado el año
pasado él hizo que unos granjeros
mataran a un jefe whatsapp y también y
es a causa de él que la deforestación ha
aumentado porque no castiga
en simbad en nuestro territorio por eso
les pido su ayuda
el año pasado brasil batió un triste
récord nunca en más de 10 años habían
sido asesinados tantos defensores
indígenas nunca se habían incendiado
tantas hectáreas de selva trajo ni
incumple levemente el duelo tradicional
y sale de su casa para visitar un
curandero en otro pueblo
después de varias horas bajo una lluvia
torrencial llegamos a la br 163 una
carretera de barro en medio del
territorio kayapó una zona que debería
estar protegida el gobierno brasileño
quiere pavimentar la para facilitar el
transporte de soya y de ganado
que me diga que con el norte
siempre lucharé contra esta carretera
es un símbolo del invasor como la
represa de belo monte
es muy peligroso esta ruta trae
enfermedades y destrucción
creo yo
[Música]
el año pasado ya ir bolsonaro aprobó un
proyecto de ley para abrir los
territorios indígenas a la explotación
minera y agrícola estos campos de soya
se encuentran al lado de este pueblo de
la etnia true may
el valle el jefe curandero es quien
recibe aragón
yo mi mujer y mis hijos tememos por
raonic
porque es la única persona que nos
define y que lucha por nosotros ya que
eso nos preocupa porque hasta ahora no
hemos visto a nadie que ya esté listo
para tomar su relevo cuando él ya no
esté aquí sustituye el así que eso nos
preocupa mucho
durante tres días el pañuelo para
respirar esta mezcla de humo de hierbas
los bailarines irán y vendrán a ritmos
irregulares en la casa donde ramón y se
encuentra protegido de las cámaras
[Música]
[Aplausos]
aún así entre dos ceremonias nos envía
un último mensaje tuve una visión en esa
visión un espíritu me decía yo
raoni matan a los animales y a los
pájaros y sus espíritus se rebelan
creo que la tierra se rebelará contra
nosotros los hermanos si no hacemos nada
quiero que le transmitan ese mensaje al
mundo like
la idea de dibujar la corte penal
internacional no está obligada a darle
curso a la denuncia pero raonic no ha
dicho su última palabra en este contexto
ambiental político sanitario y social
por primera vez desde su elección una
mayoría de brasileños desean la
destitución del presidente